das bundesheer ist für jede region
wichtig wenn es wo stationiert ist wenn
nicht nur durch die einkäufe direkt
durch die truppen in der region sondern
vor allem dass sich die bediensteten und
soldatinnen und soldaten welche
ansiedeln und hier leben verbringen eine
region sehr bereich es ist natürlich
auch eine ausstellung von
internationalen unternehmen quasi am
platz vorhanden und das ist ein
wichtiger bereich dass neben der
flugshow haben wir hier auch natürlich
viele wirtschaftliche kontakte und auch
anknüpfen und ich glaube diese
kombination ist ein wichtiger bereich
auch für die wirtschaft und für die
gesamte region
die hertha ist eine veranstaltung die
mich persönlich interessiert das
flugzeug interessiert bin unter flugzeug
auf ihn meine karriere eigentlich 1987
als zeitsoldatin der flieger werft 2
gestartet hat jetzt schon seit vielen
jahren selbstständig bin und betrieb
haben mit 50 mitarbeitern wo man
internationale kunden beliefern und
natürlichste ehrbar chance für uns die
internationalen kontakte und das
netzwerk auch zu verstärken und auch
neue kontakte die sehr wichtig sind für
uns auch zu knüpfen
die wirtschaftskammer stolz über diese
jahrzehntelange partnerschaft das
österreichische bundesheer ist ein
wichtiger wirtschaftsfaktor in der
region und in der steiermark und diese
partnerschaft zeigt natürlich auch dass
wir gemeinsam hand in hand hier für die
wirtschaft einen großen beitrag leisten
können und darauf sind wir stolz und das
wollen wir auch in zukunft weiterhin zu
machen
wohl auch ein zusammenhalten